people we have a treat for you as we are
a show that's on every day and we're
practically live we feel it's our
responsibility to take what we are alive
wink we feel it's our responsibility to
bring you some up to the date news
stories and as you may have noticed
Andy's not here right now he's actually
in Atlanta at the moment we've sent Andy
to Atlanta to cover the whole Superbowl
thing Andy Andy you there hi hey Conan
I need a 10-letter word for rubber shoe
projections Andy it's one of those ones
with a question mark so it's kind of
jokey or something you know yeah
Andy Andy we have stuff to do here all
right once you put the puzzle away now
we're all very excited this is a big
expensive thing for us to do we've sent
you all the way to Atlanta what's the
story down there I don't know there's
like some football game that's going on
yeah Andy we know there's a football
thing going on but what's the story I
mean what's going on and you've mixed it
up down there you probably know what's
happening I know I don't know you know I
don't know anything about football and I
I couldn't care less actually which
actually can get in trouble around here
I've already found that out but I mean I
I don't know why you just sent me well
Andy I have to admit it I I thought it
would be good if you and I got away from
each other for a while
you know just for a day I knew I was
being punished no Andy you're not being
punished this is just this makes sense I
mean come on sometimes don't I get on
your nerves yeah yeah all right now you
do that's all right you don't have to
elaborate now there must be loads of
people there come on just mingle a
little find out about this big game okay
hi sir
what's your name I'm brookmire and what
do you do Oh Andy he's a well-known
football player just just ask him about
the game come on okay well as a
well-known football player are you
nervous about the big game and why
aren't you wearing your football clothes
Andy Andy the guy is with the Seahawks
he's not he's not playing oh so what's
your prediction for the big game
who's it gonna be Cowboys or buffaloes
okay well
yeah look I understand you filed a
report earlier can we take a look at
that you have a little something to show
us
Oh either tape piece yeah the tape piece
oh yeah well earlier well thanks Rick
we're there
yeah thank you holy gleaned a lot from
that Andy that was terrific of
everything earlier today I went to the
Hyatt and that's where all the media
people are there's all this hubbub lots
of wires and guys with cowboy hats
covered in snakeskin and we taped this
piece we're all here for the Super Bowl
everyone we see is already on station
all around the country here to tell
people what's going to happen in a big
game
wouldn't it be more simple just to send
one guy to tell all the radio stations
how much you come here they give you
free stuff now no I mean like where in
the building are they giving out the
free stuff which is located one floor
down they just tell them fall Tigers we
section mine okay I'm here with your
name Wendy spender and you're with the
NFL yes I was with the Patriots okay
the Patriots so that's a team right New
England all right so I guess I should
register because that's how I okay
airless NBC all right okay yeah do you
have any bags that don't say Super Bowl
on yeah do you have anything other than
bags cuz I already have a bag that I
brought with me
okay how hard how hard do you think that
this stitching would be to take out okay
well thanks Wendy for the bag and all
okay all right thanks it's kind of it's
kind of ugly
[Music]
yeah really thank you thank you very
much for that I think we all really sort
of know the scoop down there now thank
you very much for your report and I
guess we'll try and maybe check in on
you a little later if you happen to
cough up anything more substantial okay
oh I'll try I guess all right well
that's the important thing
Andy is they before we continue with the
show I thought let's just take one more
quick stab at Andy I gave him a stern
talking-to over the commercial break and
I'm sure he's coughed up something Andy
Andy are you there can you hear me hi
Andy Andy what's that what's that crap
on the screen would you get that off
it's a puppy smelling of flour
yeah they're busy so anyway please just
do me a favor I'm in touch with the
network if you don't cough up someone is
there anyone there that that you found
is running when they're you could talk
to who'd have a great perspective on the
game and what's going on um
I know sir could you come here hi I'm
Andy Richter from late-night hi what's
true now you hi hi what do you do are
you Andy
Andy that's Travis Tritt he's a very
famous country singer oh you're a very
famous country singer from what I hear
yeah it's in here it's Andy tell him you
love his music I love your music
I guess thank you very much
you're welcome so who do you think the
Buffaloes or the Cowboys
Buffalo's I mean the Buffalo Bills
yeah yeah whatever I think it's gonna be
the cowboy all right yeah well I'm
Travis thinks it's the Cowboys do you
have any questions form Conan no I I
don't really know much about football or
country music Andy but listen I thank
him very much and keep looking you're
doing a fantastic job we're all very
very proud of you okay thanks
Travis says bye no he didn't
all right well I'm just trying to make
things right
I'm so sorry oh he's the only guy we
could send yeah forget it we are gonna
check in with Andy right now he's back
in Atlanta we're all very excited I know
this time he has a real gem for us Andy
are you there hi corn you think they put
a dome up over these things cuz they're
afraid of blimp attacks Andy I I really
wouldn't know now oh it's a nice thought
you have though tell us what's going on
down there well um they're just
rehearsing part of the halftime show
guess who's part of it take a look look
go
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah apparently he's like got in a big
solo number that he's doing and that's
terrific I'm looking forward to that on
Sunday yeah that's probably the only
thing I'll watch all right well tell me
I understand you spoke to some New York
radio guy is that correct yeah some mad
dog or something like that I don't know
exactly but he's he talked a lot but
what's your name my name is Christopher
man to a gruesome Mad Dog is is that a
given name no no it's not a given name
Mad Dog I'm a nutty guy from New York
and I scream and yell and I go wild and
superb all the game you know guy from
New York that screams that's the real
rarity that is rare that's you Andy
you're awfully mellow uh what is it this
is super ball got me to you you got
tagged leave ooh you got who do you like
who do you like for the game Dallas or
the Buffaloes I want to take buffaloes
this year they've lost three in a row
but I'm gonna take him for the heck of
it
close game late field goal I think
they're gonna be all pumped up they
obviously are the underdog but I'm gonna
take the bills this year instead of the
Cowboys I'm taking the buffaloes Buffalo
Bills up in Buffalo New York
Cowboys at Troy Aikman they won it last
year 52 17 nine turnovers make we did a
great job Bills last year got killed
they've lost three in a row Giants beat
him four years ago this all coming back
to you a little bit no I really don't
know what are you liking again um I
don't know I'll probably be doing
laundry that day won't you the game is
that well that's 6:20 at night on Sunday
night you gonna be doing laundry well
it's a good time to do laundry because
everybody's by nine loads I guarantee of
that you're not you're not
you just know you're a big guy yeah no I
don't have a lot of what do you like in
a game I don't know I guess I'll say the
Buffaloes well why would you just
because I say the Buffaloes know I've
been wrong a thousand times don't go by
me because I like the name yes
there Kona and I guess I better thank
you Andy thank you very much it happens
believe me it happens a lot other shows
have that problem all right we're gonna
be right back with Yo La Tengo I think
that's it for Andy but stick around